man cela ressemble souvent à un parcours
du combattant tenter d'arrêter de fumer
un supplice pour certains mais il existe
pourtant des solutions comme la
cigarette électronique ou des coffrets
cadeaux qui propose un séminaire avec
des psychologues spécialistes du sevrage
diego garcia héloïse mallet et régis
mater contrairement aux apparences
hélène vient d'arrêter de fumer elle a
abandonné le vrai tabac pour la
cigarette électronique qui ne contient
aucun des quatre mille poisot présent
dans une cigarette classique
autre avantage elle est autorisée dans
les lieux publics et ne provoque pas de
tabagisme passif et j'ai ça ça me va me
va très bien c'est ça c'est vraiment
tous les avantages de entre guillemets
de l'e cigarette sans les inconvénients
c'est à dire je m'applique à la santé je
ne sens pas le tabac je peux fumer je
veux pas d'interdiction alors au bureau
elle ne la quitte pas à la grande
surprise de ses collègues
j'ai eu quelques fois des réflexions qui
sont on n'a pas droit de fumer dans les
bureaux et jeudi mais je sais mais ceci
n'est pas une vraie cigarette et
pourtant elle en a le goût et la fumée
grâce à un diffuseur électronique et une
cartouche de rechange avec ou sans
nicotine jetables ou rechargeables on
trouve cette cigarette en pharmacie
entre 20 et 79 euros il est comme
n'importe quel produit anti tabac comme
le patch les goûts le comprimé mais ça
c'est une nouvelle façon d'arrêter de
fumer
mais pour ce spécialiste cette cigarette
avec nicotine pourrait avoir des effets
pervers
toutes les formes de nicotine sont
addictives créer une addiction crée une
dépendance et après on va être obligé de
prendre sa nicotine et puis au cours de
sa vie on prendra la nicotine sous la
forme voilée disponibles soit la
cigarette qui est une forme relativement
toxiques soit par forme orale ou avec ce
type de produits
autre produit autre alternative le
coffret cadeau incluant un séminaire de
quatre heures et un suivi personnalisé
par internet le tout pour 199 euros mais
les clients sont sceptiques
qu'est ce qui va à croire à ça puisque
même les patchs les gens
les médecins nous disent que même avec
les patchs et vendu avec conseils mais
ça que c'est pas efficace l'aide au
sevrage
un marché juteux en développement
constant et pour cause près de 20
millions de français fument
régulièrement au moins une cigarette par
jour